the Congressional response to the virus
much debate on Capitol Hill about the
way forward joining us this evening
New York Democratic congresswoman
Alexandria Acacio Cortez congresswoman
thanks for being here thank you for
having me what's your concern what do
you think Congress will do well I think
what we're seeing right now are a lot of
dramatic developments this week in
response to the corona virus both with
our public health and in our economic
response and so what we need to do is
act swiftly to not just concentrate on
solutions for Wall Street but we need to
provide relief for working Americans
Americans who are living off of tips who
are getting laid off whoo-hoo shifts are
being canceled all of a sudden and we
need to make sure that we act very
quickly and that's why I think it's
imperative that we pass the bill that's
been presented today which includes paid
sick leave which includes extended
unemployment benefits protections for
Medicaid and also making sure that we're
taking action to protect doctors and
nurses and hospital workers on the front
line there's been some negotiations
between Speaker Pelosi and Treasury
secretary minuchin apparently all day
long and obviously there is a concern
about what the Senate will do or won't
do with the House bill the payroll tax
holiday never really took off Democrats
you weren't there at the time but they
were supportive of it under President
Obama doesn't work this time I think
what we need to see is what tools we use
for what responses so a payroll tax is
one thing to be considered when there
are certain economic indicators but
right now what we are dealing with is a
pandemic and so what we need to make
sure is that we're taking swift actions
right now to protect doctors to protect
people on Medicaid to make sure that
people can see a doctor and those are
the things that we need to be focusing
on right now we can talk about a payroll
tax later you can talk about you know
debate all of these sorts of things at
another time but right now is the moment
for swift action to make sure we're
protecting our elders and our
immunocompromised Americans I want to
play what President Trump said yesterday
about politics Nicholas we have the best
economy the most advanced health care
and the most talented doctors scientists
and researchers anywhere in the world we
are all in this
together we must put politics aside stop
the partisanship and unified together as
one nation and one family agree with
that well I think one thing that we need
to do is put politics aside and that's
exactly why Democrats have agreed with
president Trump on his goals have paid
sick leave and his goals of free
coronavirus testing and so all of those
things have been included in our package
we bump it up a little bit more but you
know in when you have a Democratic House
in a Republican Senate compromises the
name of the game I think the president's
gonna have to accept the fact that we're
fighting for people who are gonna be
potentially unemployed he's gonna have
to accept the fact that we're gonna push
on doctor and nurse protections but also
when you look at the best you know the
best health care system in the world
that's something that's up for debate
South Korea we're up to South Korea is
up to 10,000 tests per day they've been
able to provide tests to any single
person that wants it and here people are
scrambling and it almost seems like the
more wealthy and powerful you are the
more able you're able the more able you
are to access a test but the more you
know the the rougher a road you've got
here it's going to be a lot more
difficult for you to access health care
that's exactly the recipe for disaster
in a pandemic dr. Thatcher you testified
that there is a failing on the testing
up on Capitol Hill but on the politics
front it's only two weeks ago you
tweeted out Mike Pence literally does
not believe in science it is utterly
irresponsible to put him in charge of us
coronavirus response as the world sits
on the cusp of a pandemic this decision
could cost people their lives Pence's
past decisions already have obviously
the vice president Pence was the head of
the coronavirus task force but dr.
Anthony Falchi the head of the CDC all
those other scientists were also a part
of it isn't that politics well you know
I disagree with the appointment of vice
president pence I have made that
extraordinarily clear but at the end of
the day he's there so we need to focus
on the actions that need to be happening
right now and the actions that need to
be happening is making sure that we're
taking care of people who are going to
be hurting as a result of this again
this is not just this is a public health
crisis but it's also an economic crisis
and on the public health front we have a
lot of
or who are older and who are
immunocompromised in this country and
the corona virus is has been testified
from the CDC director as ten times more
lethal than the flu sure and then the
people point to the h1n1 virus and it
killed a lot of people in the US and
there is a wonder whether you know where
the the perfect response is whether we
go too far whether we don't go far
enough you're saying we should just not
worry about that now I think we
shouldn't worry about it right now
in fact you know one thing that I will
agree with is that we should not be
panicking but we should be preparing and
if we are at a standstill here in
Washington and we aren't getting these
things passed and we aren't willing to
compromise and negotiate for folks who
are gonna be unemployed and folks who
need these helps in hospitals folks who
are on Medicaid then there are going to
be people who will get hurt by this so
we need to take action right now we have
to depoliticize it right now we're
hearing that some of the fights and some
of the the gridlock is because people
are trying to put pro-life provisions
into this we can have that debate
another time we understand that we'd
agree that we disagree on some Democrats
trying to add stuff too I mean it
becomes a Christmas tree up there when
big bills are passed but to your point I
want to ask you a couple questions about
the race presidential race you're Bernie
Sanders most prominent surrogate was it
difficult to witness his kind of swift
fall from frontrunner status he's almost
a protest candidate now your thoughts
well I think one of the things that we
saw with Bernie Sanders his leadership
even today is how transformative it is
for the American people just today he
laid out a very strong plan in response
for the coronavirus for everyday people
for Main Street not just Wall Street
he's talking about how do we make sure
that everyone who needs access to
Medicare can get it and that that
Medicare is improved and expanded how do
we make sure that people aren't getting
booted out of their homes whether it's
not being able to afford their mortgage
payment this month we're not being able
to afford their rent payment but it does
seem like Joe Biden is on his way to the
nomination are you worried that he's not
going to be saying those things well you
know I think this part of our of our
process is to make sure
we come together I think there's going
to be a real vigorous debate and I
believe Sunday night if I'm not mistaken
and part of that process means that I
think we will come together and you know
I think Bernie Sanders has done a great
job and it's continuing to do a great
job of pushing to make sure that we have
a party agenda that fights for working
people last thing you did a campaign
event at the University of Michigan had
10,000 people it was like a rock star
status but those kids did not show up at
least if you look at the numbers I'm
just over all this with this race so how
can you say the progressive position is
still prevailing nationwide when Joe
Biden is winning so much well I think
one thing that we that isn't being
talked about is the rampant voter
suppression in this country right there
in Ann Arbor where we had that rally
those kids were waiting three hours in
line to vote in Michigan and so when we
talk about who's turning out and who's
not turning out we absolutely just to be
clear you're saying that you think
voters didn't get to vote they wanted to
vote in Michigan absolutely you know
obviously there's also more that we need
to do in terms of turning out youth
voters it's we need to make sure that
we're inspiring young people to turn out
but when you do turn out you should not
be waiting three four seven hours in
order to vote yes that causes people
you're working with in the system now on
this legislation you've struck some
conciliatory tomes to tonight and on
Capitol Hill at the same time you're
backing primary challenges for your
leadership Jerry Nadler Steny Hoyer oh
that's not correct no no I'm not backing
primary challengers for those two but I
have back primary challengers for
growing list of primary challengers have
you back to Steny Hoyer eliot engel
Jerry Nadler cut your nails no but I
have back primary challengers to dan
Lipinski and Henry Cuellar okay so how
do you square that well I think that
there are places where we can do better
and when we talk about not being
partisan I think just as Republicans can
look in depth at in their own backyard
and say this is what we can do better I
think that Democrats can look in our own
backyard and say there are places where
we can do better too and I think that if
you are taking big-money and if you are
relying on lobbyist funds and you aren't
answering to your constituents back home
you should be held accountable and I
don't think that
incumbency should be a thing that's
guaranteed and I even apply that to
myself and I understand that promise
when we appreciate your tongue of course
thank you for having me